guten morgen neben mir steht der
pressesprecher hat ist egal sachsen der
polizei sachsen der herr geithner und
ich gebe mal gleich die frage weiter wo
wird denn in berlin zurzeit durch so wir
haben insgesamt 18 das perfekte ihr in
berlin verteilt über das ganze
stadtgebiet wenn sie warten schlafen
punkt gibt dann sind es die stadtbezirk
neukölln und kreuzberg
was hat man denn heute durchsucht und
was macht mann festnehmen was man schon
wie viele festnahmen es gab ja wir
hatten zwei ziele unser einsatz heute
ist zum einen die tus suchen insgesamt
18 objekte
das sind zum großteil wohnungen
vereinzelt auch garagen und fahrzeuge
gesucht wurden natürlich die
kunstgegenstände zum einen aber auch
klassische beweismittel wie
bekleidungsgegenstände werkzeuge oder
speichermedien die durchsuchung werde
noch ein bisschen dauern das hängt von
der größe des objektes ab wo wir schon
einen strich machen können sind drei
festnahmen drei männer festgenommen
deutsche staatsangehörige die im klaren
wie zu hause sind die werden noch heute
im tagesverlauf in dresden ein
ermittlungsrichter vorgeführt
konnten sie dann schon irgendwas finden
oder andere zufallsfunden die auf andere
straftaten hindeuten dass wir uns noch
zu früh da warten jetzt die versuchung
ab wir werden am ende das einzig noch
mal ein fazit ziehen insbesondere was
wir für sich gefunden haben aber noch
sind wir mitten drinnen da ist es
einfach noch zu früh
ja also wir gerade gehört haben die
arbeiten hier noch mit hochdruck an
allen objekten dran und die
spezialkräfte am im augenblick noch
nicht alles richten können was es so
eigentlich alles in den wohnungen und
den garagen gefunden worden
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dir das nächste video an
und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren